hey everybody jimmy pardon here for the
pardo patrol i'm outside of chris
pratt's dressing room he just did a
great segment with conan uh you can
currently see him on parks and
recreation and the new movie money ball
let's go inside see what happens hello
hello sneaky behind the door get out i
need you out chris my name is me pardo i
apologize for just uh kicking those
people out without your permission are
you comfortable with me getting rid of
them
no really who are you i'm jimmy part i
work here on the program conan tell me
if that's weird is that weird
those are some fun things let's talk
about those thighs um
excuse me what is it what is it what are
we doing here we do these first of all
let's watch that language i saw you
tried to go a little blue let's not do
that this is still respectful and i
appreciate if you would do it okay i'm
sorry i know i'm sorry what i did is i
came in here i knocked on the door like
a gentleman yes i cleared the room so
you and i could have a little time sorry
to promote your movie and your
television program
and then i was thrown by the firmness of
that thigh okay thanks yeah what did you
do squats
i would i would credit most most most of
that to genetics i think you've always
had firm thighs as a baby they're they
were
that you know i it was a point in my
life where i would notice that oh hey
you got from firmer thighs than normal
you do this parks and recreation program
yes and uh your character is kind of
dumb right
are you when you do that are you acting
or cause do you think maybe you're a
little dumb too i'm asking is it
typecast jerry right jimmy jimmy i
appreciate
what we're doing here
i think i get it yeah i think i get
what's going on i'm kind of i came what
do you mean what's going on i compliment
the thighs firm
and then i'm complimenting you're
hitting on me pardon me
and i'm okay with that
i want you to know do you think i'm
pretty sure
you do
i don't know what that means but i'm in
let's do this thing
let's do this shut that down you're
rolling no no no no let's keep it
rolling jimmy let's make the move let's
do it we'll see you next time on the paw
patrol woo team coco